I was approached by by a friend to come
build this technology for Tesla I saw
what they were doing and I'm like I am
confident with the research I've seen
that I can beat that no one day I was
just like you know I'm gonna go buy a
car I'm gonna throw some cameras in it
throw some computers in it we're just
gonna make this work done as yourself
what what is self-driving right um so a
lot of cars already have cruise control
in some ways cruise control is a is a
self-driving car and then some cars have
adaptive cruise control which that does
the brake automatically and what we're
building is is level 3 automation a
level 3 automation 99% of the time you
have to do absolutely nothing except
watch the car drive and level 4
automation is of course when cars can
drive with no people in them at all
George Hotz I'm about to be the next
billion-dollar CEO I don't know what
else you want George Hotz came onto the
scene as a 17 year old hacking
phenomenon he was the first person to
break up in the iPhone and the first
person to hack Sony's PlayStation he
spent a few years working odd jobs
around Silicon Valley and competing in
security competitions now after two
years in virtual hiding he's come out to
show the world what might be his
greatest invention yet you can doubt and
you should doubt
I doubt everyone who says everything but
once I see it you can't doubt anymore
right Petie tap into the cars internal
controls um so we bought for $40 off
Amazon Chinese can transceivers is
actually one right there we can see all
the messages being sent between the
components that's how we're reading the
steering angle and we can also send our
own messages which are going to tell the
car actually turns to wheel it'll apply
the brakes but it's broken is it hard it
happened all that or that's what a
mechanic would do today I have access to
the same kind of system the actual whole
car is on the debugging part of the car
so we just have a wire plug into the
report just like a mechanic window
it just seems crazy to me that you can I
mean not anyone could do it you
obviously know what you're doing but
then you can kind of plug in to the car
then start getting all the foods for us
doing the petals of the turn signal
modern cars are very electronic and
computer aspect we I don't been about
cars I'm not like a real car guy but I'm
computer guy
cars are computers there's kind of two
two halves right I worked on both of
those halves independently it's like
let's build up good models of how
driving works and what I should output
given these inputs and then over here
I'm like okay let's hook up a joystick
to the brakes and the gas and the
steering so that I can steer the car
entirely digital and then once you have
this part and this part in the same
computer just a question of connecting
them together
the self-driving cars that are on the
road today continue to rely on very
expensive sensors and clunky software
hot PSA's car uses similar sensors like
lidar for training his AI software but
the cars he plans to sell one day will
only need a set of six smartphone
cameras that cost $13 a pop to see the
road and hots of software will take care
of the rest
he thinks the total cost for his
self-driving package will be about
$1,000 so we detach the car from the
home network and this is the plug
powering all the computers I'm just
going to plug that into a power inverter
here which will power it all off the car
now we're ready to go how do you teach a
car drive some people might think that
what you do is you give it all these
rules about Drive you tell it all these
well you know if there's a car a little
bit over there you should give it a
little bit of space and you know if
there's a there's always like very rigid
rules like you should stay in the exact
center of the lane um but this isn't how
humans drive this might be how humans
think they drive but it isn't how they
actually drive so how do humans learn to
drive well they watch other people drive
and then they try and they get better
and that's exactly what we're doing here
so right now we're just in the washing
phase we have not told this car anything
about driving we've shown it 10 hours of
human driving footage and we're like
here is what the human did behave like
that human as much right
and you get in this intuition and never
get a little based system this is round
3 10 hours per car I'm learning the
drive does it drive like a person that's
been driving for 10 hours is it better
it's driving like a person that's been
driving for 10 hours which you'd be
surprised there's a lot between that 5
and 10 mark already now it's totally
driving by it's not cars completely
driving by itself you want the car to
start modeling the people around they
want the car to know what people are
about the point is to drive naturally
like a human not like some engineer's
idea of safety and when you get on the
highway press this one and always
remember you don't like what the car is
doing press cancel it'll give you full
manual control back here goes nothing
with present good yeah
that is crazy
it was hard to yeah commit yourself with
my number one oh he's very safe
following distance talk about you
this is driving man I gotta be honest I
mean I didn't think it'd be that good
yeah that like wouldn't what I write I
am what I think when I Drive with you
usually it's just really hard for me to
tell are you to tell how much the
computer is doing exactly where I wanted
to let you dry out is correct hot still
has a ton of work ahead of him to prove
that this technology can work but spend
an afternoon with him and you can't help
get the feeling he's on to something
fantastic and that this may be a huge
breakthrough not only in self-driving
cars but also for artificial
intelligence technology I think that a
lot of companies today are just did a
really poor job on I'd be way off base I
might be there might turn out to be a
reason why everyone does what they do
sometimes I've seen that but sometimes
I've seen it just took a new set of eyes
to come in and be like hey wait a second
we can do everything better and you
don't really what's all about too is
it's about having fun
it's about it's not about you know I'm
never going to say that we're changing
the world I mean we are but that's not
like that rhetoric has been hijacked
what this is about is actually building
really cool things that we want in the
world